[Music]
extraordinary comeback of the former
metal worker who became one of the
world's most influential Progressive
leaders is a game changer especially for
Brazil Latin America's largest economy
I consider myself to be a candidate
who's had a process of reconstruction in
Brazilian politics because my rivals
tried to bury me alive and here I am
here to govern the country from a very
difficult situation
among those difficulties the acceptance
of his narrow electoral Victory truck
drivers who support far right-wing
president Jade bolsonaro are blocking
highways in at least 11 South and
southeastern states they are showing
their Defiance of the election outcome
Madina Silva Brazil's like the next
environmental Minister says this is a
balso narrow version of the capital
Takeover in Washington
leaders of both houses of Brazil's
Congress have congratulated Lula but in
an unprecedented move president
bolsonaro is so far refusing to concede
defeat or even speak publicly and that
could fan more calls from his supporters
from military intervention
this is a fraud and if the people have
to call on the Army the Army must
intervene communism will not be allowed
in Brazil
by contrast Lula has received scores of
congratulatory messages including one
from U.S President Joe Biden who
described the election as free fair and
credible Da Silva is wasting no time
putting Brazil back on the international
map starting with his own region Latin
America a short while ago Alberto
Fernandez the president of Argentina
which is the second largest country in
Latin America arrived here to meet with
Lula and they are going to make a very
important announcement and that is the
return of Brazil to select that is the
regional organization that was created
by Lula when he was first president
along with the former president of
Venezuela Hugo Chavez but bolsonaro
withdrew Brazil from that Forum now
Brazil is going to be again taking a
leadership role
but first Lula will have to put his own
house in order to begin to heal the
wounds from a political battle for the
hearts and minds of Brazilians which has
divided this country as never before
[Applause]
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera Sao Paulo